I see a man who wrote a great games
story which is kind of old-school in
itself writing game stories for si.com
and also the Fox Sports sideline college
football analyst in general we love
having here in the show fresh back from
the Rose Bowl good to see you Bruce
Feldman how are you sir every new year
itch so uh that game last night was just
spectacular that was a fun
back-and-forth that was a lot of just
forth for Oklahoma how did you see that
game changing you know a lot rich like
last year we had an awesome Rose Bowl
Penn State sacrum Berkeley and Tracy
McSorely going off against Sam Donald in
USC well obviously what's different with
this is there's way more stakes you know
involved because it's for a shot to win
the national title I was not surprised
in Oklahoma jumped all over them
offensively because I just think Georgia
and and that defense hadn't seen
anything like like Baker Mayfield in
that offense I thought Lincoln Rawley
did a great job as a play caller early
on especially in the first half the one
thing he looked at was man the Georgia
running backs are running wild you know
at one point Nick Chubb and stony
Michele those are the two two running
backs we're averaging 20 yards of carry
and that was like it deeps into the
second half it wasn't like in the first
you know two series and so once they got
rolling I think Georgia made some good
adjustments where they they did some
things up with their defensive line did
they do they did a lot more twisting and
a lot more a lot more stunning that they
hadn't done in the first half no when I
talked to the Oklahoma staff they said
we saw it on film but it's just they got
not a lot more aggressive and we
struggled to match their intensity and I
think if you're looking at Oklahoma two
years ago people forget this they
actually were leading Clemson I had to
shout deshaun Watson yeah and then they
got blown out 21 to nothing in the
second half and Clemson goes on to play
for the national title this felt similar
to it but obviously Oklahoma got back in
the game they had the the forced fumble
for the touchdown but at the end I mean
you know a lot of credit to Georgia
that's the first time on this big stage
and I thought they're true freshman
quarterback Jake ROM played really well
spectacular I could not believe you know
we were fortunate my
I took my wife and kids to to the game
and we were fortunate we were sitting in
front of Terry front of Terry Donahue
mm-hmm and you know who is the mule
alleged yes I mean his name's on the
side of the building based you know
where you can walk into certain parts of
the stadium and he could not believe him
we couldn't both of us everyone around
it this kid was in high school one year
ago and yet he could not believe seeing
that he's like this kid was in high
school he's a true freshman right he was
not supposed to be the guy their
starting quarterback Jacob Eason who has
a bigger arm and came in with probably
even more hype he was the true freshman
quarterback who's the starter at the
beginning of the year and then gets hurt
hurts his knee against Appalachian State
and then Fromm goes in there plays well
and then basically just holds him off
and you know again I was really
impressed I expected the running backs
to play well I didn't expect him to be
that as sharp as he was no mistakes and
you just you just when they were
marching down the field to tie the game
to send it in overtime it would have
been a shocker to me if he made a
mistake because he was playing so
mistake-free and just commas cool as a
cucumber remember that's the kid that
was like a Little League World Series
hero so he's got some back stories your
mom you know the amazing thing about
Georgia just a little bit of a sidebar
to this is so two years ago they get
Jacob Eason from Washington State was a
huge recruit for them and then this year
Jake Fromm goes and so he got
back-to-back starting quarterbacks were
true freshmen and on top of it now they
have a more talented Kommandant kid
coming in in a few weeks Justin fields
from from he's a Georgia kid he's a lot
of people think he's the top-rated
quarterback to come out of high school
in like the last three years he's going
and they're people think he's gonna end
up overtake and overtake him both of
them by next year like if yeah he could
win the championship and then come back
as a novice on that's what Kirby smart
and Jim Chaney the elephants coordinator
preach and so can you believe that Brock
that's crazy well you probably not
thrilled because he was committed to
Penn State for a while no well I'll take
anybody but and by the way
congratulations on your school having
something in common with Alabama know
being Clemson it goes before we get to
that though I want to just linger a
little bit more on the Rose Bowl here
with with Bruce Feldman who was there
you were you were witness to an
interesting moment on the field after
the
for those who did not read your column
and there your store and they should at
si.com or follow you on twitter which
they should at bruce Feldman cfb what
recount what you saw so hey you know in
the course of the game he kind of decide
you know I was working with another
writer for Sports Illustrated and you
know he was gonna work on something on
Georgia and so Baker made for the
Heisman Trophy winner he's a big story
so like hard I'm gonna follow Baker you
know in this you know kind of
post-mortem situation and you see him go
down the line and graduate and console
all his teammates and then he gets that
he goes on the field to start
approaching some Georgia players and
he's looking for Jake Fromm and he's
just going up the different Georgia
players and then davon Bellamy who's a
linebacker for Georgia he's like in the
middle of an interview and you could
just hear him from a long way away just
scream and humble yourself humble
yourself and he must have said it you
know through at least at least three
times and just you know I asked Baker
after the game you know like a half hour
later when we're in the locker and I
said you know yeah I know you you get
after guys and you get pretty emotional
too I said do you hear that and he said
yeah but but uh you know they won the
game they get the right to talk that's
well I'm first of all I'm glad to hear
that he's the hey walk it if you can
walk it regardless if he's the one who
is on the business end of being walked
upon I guess to use that phrase sure but
did did he put up a choke sign in the
Jews own yesterday he got asked about
that and he said that was directed
towards his own teammates and you got a
step on their throat he said you know
obviously when you get a team down
you gotta that's what you're supposed to
do and we did not obviously do it did
anyone ask Lincoln Riley about maybe
going for it another time yeah I didn't
hear any of the postgame Jeff he was
asked that what he said he just said you
know there's a lot of stuff you always
Rio valuate he really thought about it
twice and I even called the timeout nice
the kid he had a lot of chances to he
first of all they called timeout then
there was an icing of the cake there was
a lot of time for anything and then
Georgia didn't have a timeout they make
a you know their field goal block the
field goal team is on the field so if
they did something different I would
have loved you remember like those
cartoon bubble thoughts that you could
have over the cartoons that I would have
loved to
had that I happen to be standing behind
Bob Stoops you know the great coach who
just retired to give a link in the job
so you were on the field for this yeah I
mean at the end I'm right behind Bob
Stoops and he's about six feet away from
Joe Castiglione the ad and Bob walks
down to you know maybe I don't know
fifteen yards down to see how close it
is and Castiglione looks over and he
goes he goes how close he was real close
or something like that and I'm just
thinking what is going through Bob
Stoops head right now cuz it's like I'm
thinking after that time they're sending
the offense back out on the field but
you're a rookie head coach can you make
that decision you know at that point I
think in Lincoln Raleigh's a really
aggressive coach and in how he calls a
game but I just don't know maybe in year
one I don't know if you can do this yeah
hindsight is tornado I know I know and
and Brockman you even said saying yeah
do you do did anyone ask Kirby smart if
he thought of going for two when they
scored with 55 I don't know if that got
asked cuz I was down at that point I'm
in you know use locker room sided and
I'm trying to remember because I looked
at the transcript if that was you know I
assume that probably was asked at some
point to him well and I guess maybe the
postgame conversations like okay now
you're taking on Nick Saban potentially
because nobody knew at the time how do
you how do you see how do you see that
matchup going down now with Kirby smart
yeah make a mean national champ they're
obviously very similar you know they're
they've structured their program the
same as the Nick Saban did both have
real physical run games kind of modest
passing games I think I think Alabama
has as you know better receivers but
what we saw last night from Alabama was
different than what we've seen from
Alabama at any point this year how so
they dominated the line of scrimmage
against a really physical team and I
think one of the big keys for Nick Saban
was that he throttled back on the
practice and how physical they were and
kind of altered his from what I was told
altered his practice schedule because he
wanted his guys to have fresh legs you
know in this day and age and I'm sure
it's that like this even as well in the
NFL but one of the come up a lot in the
last five six seven years in college
football is with all this GPS monitoring
of
of guys and their bodies at practice
coaches a lot of them at least have
become smarter in how they prepare and
how they practice and so they don't run
guys into the ground and their legs are
fresh and I think you saw that from
Alabama because the end of year Alabama
was a really beat up team especially on
the defensive side of the ball and they
were playing at a different level than
an athletic Clemson team last night I'm
not betting against even though this is
you know considered a home game for
Georgia because it's at the
mercedes-benz Stadium I don't know if
you can bet pick against against Alabama
with that experience and and what and
the way they look last night amazing if
it all comes down to just Alabama again
six times in nine years I don't think
they're gonna win you don't I don't
why are you convinced that Nick same old
team will lose this game I don't know if
they can score enough points Georgia
kind of showed a lot to me offensively
last night and I know Oklahoma's not
really known as a defensive team but
they ran roughshod over Oklahoma last
night and I think they're gonna be able
to mix it up and Fromme looks like he's
the real deal I think that's that's good
logic I that came felt like a like a big
12 game we do a lot of big 12 games
that's what it felt like you know and
Georgia was able to play a big 12 games
and Alabama didn't score a lot on
offense last night I know Clemson's
great defensively but they didn't show
me much on offense it's just man when
the lights come on and Nick Saban puts
on that headset and against a guy and
and he knows what his protege have never
beaten him never he's their own 11
against Nick really take on the boss and
even when you look at some of how
they've done like Mark Dantonio is a
terrific coach you know he was under
saving at Michigan State would they lose
31 to nothing or 38 to nothing okay
years ago gonna be epic but that kid
from your right home game for Georgia do
you think that has anything and a true
freshman beat Nick Saban in a national
championship game in that defense that's
by the way the home game for Georgia
maybe but it's not there's not gonna be
a ton of travel travel travel that far
it's like there's something about you so
I want to take a break and talk about
the next level for a lot of these pill
folks Mayfield is darn 'old coming out
don't answer that if you have a
definitive answer on that rose and Alan
all those guys what's going on and
my alma mater who set up for success in
2018 that's with Bruce Feldman of si.com
and also Fox Sports Talk in college
football with Bruce who was at the Rose
Bowl last night that's next your phone
calls also still to come a news update
from Kris Brockman Isiah Thomas coming
back tonight for the Cleveland Cavaliers
that's all coming up here in our number
three on the Rich Eisen show all right
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
Bruce Feldman fresh from the Rose Bowl
and you did a podcast last night late
last night for somewhere to doubt the
doubt of the media hotel the downtown LA
hotel so it's good it's that time of
year for it is that time it's a sprint I
do not your NFL stuff is like an
11-month a you know a year a deal yeah
college football's not that way once
past signing day it throttles down no
difficulty well I'm glad you came in
here in person again check out Bruce
Feldman's coverage on si.com of the game
last night no obviously throughout the
rest of this week and the national
championship game set for six days from
now against a in Atlanta between Georgia
and Alabama all right so let's get down
to it you were at the game last night
you sitting next to our guy our boy
Daniel Jeremiah who's act moved the
sticks who knows so much about all these
kids about what they could do for the
next level is Sam Donald best you know
is he a done deal is he coming out or
what happened against Ohio State gives
him pause and he stays in you know going
into the bowl Cotton Bowl last right now
I would have said Sam Donald was 55 45
to stay my hunch
and this is not from something anyone
told me it's the opposite now I think
it's 55 45 to go no kidding so Greg
Schiano
and that defensive line for Ohio State
shows him what could happen at the next
level and and it allows him to think
that he could he could go now cuz I
would I honestly thought you'd finish
the sentence saying now it's 70/30 he
stays cuz it's not even a guarantee
Cleveland takes him number one or the
Giants like him he might sit in that
draft room for about an hour well that's
at the next level but he doesn't have to
bring that over line with him to the
next level hopefully for his sake like
that struggled okay the things that I've
heard that people have some question is
he was I talked to clay Helton I think
two weeks ago and he said they were
going to get an evaluation back they
we should have it now um I'm pretty sure
that they would say it's gonna be a
first-round pick not like that he is
careless with the football needs to
protect it better especially with the
fumbles the interceptions is probably
another thing but the fumbles is a
bigger concern but like that he can he
will take shots and throw into tight
windows love his playmaking abilities
got good size everybody likes his
character so he's probably you know I'd
be shocked if he's not a top ten
evaluation the question is does he feel
like the USC staff can continue to
develop him and can he make a lot of
progress from two into 2018 because the
receivers are gonna be a lot better
because he had a bunch of young guys
they developed some chemistry they will
continue to get better they'll lose a
great running back in Ronald Jones but
it's USC they have a really good one in
Stephen Carr behind him the old line has
been really underwhelming and that's got
to get better and that was an issue this
year you know so I mean I thought there
was a good chance he was gonna stay now
I'm not so sure huh tell me about this
kid from Wyoming that that we're gonna
be hearing a lot about over the next to
two to three months it's being proffered
that Josh Allen is whence to point O and
thus Cleveland will be all over him what
do you think uh well he's once 2.0 in
this regard he's really big and he's got
a lot of tools in terms of big arm
athletic can make a lot of plays he also
played for Craig ball and the staff that
Wednes had at North Dakota State those
guys moved on to Wyoming and also like
whence he was a no-name recruit out of
high school nobody was interested in
them where I'm not where I'm not buying
the whens part is he his his accuracy is
very spotty and he threw a bunch of
interceptions did it last year and he
did it this year and whenever he's
played anybody who's halfway decent I'm
not talking about like Alabama defense
I'm talking about Oregon's defense
Nebraska's defense last year he's really
struggled to me again and though you'll
hear a lot of evaluation cuz his film he
can do some amazing yield some amazing
throws I would be a little concerned
just a a lot about the decision-making
but also about just the accuracy issues
and and we'll see I'm sure people are
gonna fall in love with them but I could
see it going I could see it going the
other way to Bruce Feldman here on the
Rich Eisen show Josh Rosen he's gone
right he's gone from everything I've
heard he's told people you say he's
leaving alright she's told Chip Kelly
that essential I wouldn't say but I
think he's told from what I've heard
he's told people around you say that
he's what are folks saying about his
next level viability number one overall
has a talent to be number one it will be
with meetings and how people feel
comfortable with Harry Potter just think
I mean everybody seems to think that you
know he's he doesn't want to do this
that he's got a rich parents he doesn't
need to do it he just so why the hell
has he been playing football what does
he even care that it makes no sense to
me that that people really are gonna
pass on him because they think what it
all comes down a week 16 would do or
dies ik yeah I've got rich parents know
that part of it I think so this kid was
a very competitive kid he was a great
youth tennis player transition to
football where he's he's played really
well he's got a great arm he's very
athletic you know it the the question
with him he can make all the throws
I mean touch everything seize it will
take shots you know you taught her the
other thing that I think is undervalued
about him I talk to coaches in the
pac-12 and they talk about how
physically tough he is they blitz the
heck out of him he keeps coming back the
question I think NFL personnel people
will be sorting out is you know how much
does he love football is one part of it
but it's just how well will he fit in on
the team as a leader you know it's not
weather is it you know is he a football
guy or not it's just he's a little
different I mean he's a very bright guy
he's got Cutler
know I'm not saying he's got color I I
don't know enough about Cutler's what he
was like at 21 years old okay now he has
there is a persona that get so attached
to it's just I don't know how that sits
with people I don't think Jake I don't
think Josh Rosen is surly at all you
know I've dealt with him aback when I
was in high school to back to that point
talk to a lot of you I just think it's
like will he fit in as a regular guy
that sometimes you want as the
quarterback you know crazy this business
is nutty man Bruce Feldman here on the
Rich Eisen show and then there's the
Baker Mayfield a question we don't call
him Johnny don't I I hope people don't
go so many people are saying his skill
set is Manziel like and that his ability
to hit tight windows and be accurate and
he's height challenged it's the same
thing we heard about Manziel in terms of
X's and O's forget are they off every
willing system then you know obviously
may feel how to run-in with the law blah
blah blah but it I here's the does it
three biggest differences I would make
between him and Johnny and I spent a ton
of time around both of them in college
one you can say Baker is short Baker's
not small Johnny is small johnny
struggled to get to be at 200 pounds
even when he was working you know doing
everything right Baker may feels like a
legit 215 he's a thick kid he's just
short he's six feet the other thing is
with Johnny the off the field issues
were major I mean I did a quarterback
book and you can get into some of those
there were real issues
this isn't about somebody going out and
getting drunk and being stupid you know
cuz I think if you're gonna there's a
lot of college players who would get
gone for that just people don't know who
they are
Johnny's issues were significant really
significant I don't think Baker's at the
issues I would put in that category at
all and then the third thing is and this
is a big one and I've heard this from a
lot of coaches around Baker loves
football Baker is ultra-competitive
Johnny's competitive but you Manziel
love football if he loved it as much as
because I thought johnny was a wild ride
to be around than everything
Baker was different just and like to be
to be you know not prototype size you
know if you're Russell Wilson or drew
Brees and the list isn't very long maybe
you can throw key skein at caseking
around but he hasn't I've discussed
those guys have had you know you got to
be off the charts and Russell Wilson I
always heard first guy in last guy out
Johnny was the opposite Johnny was last
guy in first guy out Baker Mayfield
won't be that so to me that's where the
difference is I think it's you know I
could see why people are throwing that
out because because a baker plays with a
humongous chip on his shoulder and
Aker plays in a non-traditional system
and he's not tall but again he's short
not small I just think you know if my
team drafted him number 20 overall I
would not bet against Baker Mayfield
couple minutes left with Bruce Feldman
here on the Rich Eisen show you've told
me over and over again that you thought
2017 would be a step back year for Jim
Harbaugh in Michigan because of how much
they lost to the NFL and that the
offense was kind of starting from
scratch five losses though is not even
close to remotely close but that's
that's to a step back that is a step in
a hole type situation
you thought 2018 was gonna be a big year
you still think so
well not 2018 the season not that not
the beginning of it but look if yeah if
and this is a big if if they can get
shaped Patterson eligible he's the old
miss transfer great arm really quick
release very competitive kid I think
he's the best quarterback college
quarterback Jim Harbaugh had since
Andrew Luck but you got to get him
eligible if they don't answer yet
doesn't clear him he doesn't get a
waiver you know I don't know if they
have it in Brandon Peters or Dylan
McCaffrey well I think Peters in any may
be fair or not I don't know I think what
what what I mean I think he played
himself out of out of the spot
personally where do you got to see what
these other young kids that are coming
in that Harbaugh is it you got
McCaffrey's younger brother you got to
see what's in those guys for sure I'm
sure there's gonna be a competition
right usually you do see a quarterback
improve from you know the end of the
regular season to the bowl game it there
was none of it well one of it passing
concepts none of it against South
Carolina we had them early on against
Purdue was a game that Wilton Speight
got hurt in right a month into the
season and he was in the stance by the
way did you see him I heard that I heard
and I'm sure somebody's gonna try to
scoop him up as a grad transfer and
think he can help him right but they
were awful in the red zone and a lot of
that was quarterback play some of those
offensive line it was it was a you know
there's a new bunch of receivers you
know one of their best receivers was
knocked out you know to read black I
think early and you know like right
around that time so what you saw I think
as a team that just didn't look like it
had all any identity on
offense and a lot of confidence and I
think that starts with the quarterback
play and I don't know like last year you
know Jed fish I thought had a really
good job for you silly made a big
difference from them they were awful
before he got their offense away and
they got a lot better this year he left
he was a passing game coordinator at
Michigan and he came to UCLA and pepp
Hamilton had to work with with with Jim
Harbaugh at Stanford he came in and
something just didn't click there you
know and I don't know what it's gonna be
like going forward because I think
they're gonna have to make some
adjustments because the rest of that
league is not getting worse Penn State
you know you know they're gonna lose say
Kwan but the quarterback still they're
they're getting better Scott frost is
coming in from Nebraska he's going to
make them batter Wisconsin's gonna be
good
Urban Meyer's gonna be recruiting well
and Michigan State is really young and
they just won 10 games you know
Maryland's gonna be better so this isn't
going to be easy
I still think you know next year this
coming season is gonna be a big year for
them but I'm curious to see what
adjustments he's made because obviously
it wasn't good enough there Bruce thanks
for coming on I love our chats you're
going to Atlanta this coming weekend I
go in Thursday it should be a should be
a interesting SEC battle ok love I look
forward to chatting with you right after
we can that's Bruce Feldman follow him
at Bruce Feldman cfb the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience